nearly 20 million people are eligible to
have their say on major amendments to
the Constitution
some of the changes include abolishing
the death penalty and establishing
greater social and legal rights
what are the guarantees of the
Constitution the referendum will solve
citizens political social and economic
issues that's why the referendum on the
amended Constitution was proposed about
65 percent of the current Constitution
will be altered
who's been in power since 2016 presents
himself as a progressive who's
modernizing Central Asia's most populous
country
there have been many changes in our
country over the last seven years and I
believe there will be more changes in
the future
the proposals would also increase the
president's term from five to seven
years a two-term limit remains but if
passed it would effectively reset the 65
year old's time in office
with his second term set to expire in
2026 two more longer terms could see
mirzy oyev govern until 2040.
while some uzbeks welcome the promise of
Reform organizations such as Human
Rights Watch still consider Uzbekistan a
deeply authoritarian State a country in
which civil liberties freedom of speech
and a free and independent media are
curtailed
in recent years Uzbekistan even adopted
legislation that criminalizes any online
criticism of the president
but every effort is being made to get
people to the polls
we have sections for the voting process
for National and foreign observers as
well as for the media we have set up
four booths for voters including one for
those with disabilities according to the
law if voters cannot come we will take
mobile booths to their houses
the results of the referendum is
expected in 10 days time Mike label Al
Jazeera